all right so what do we do at the end we
have the here's what we do at the end of
the thing okay as we do something called
unhelpful advice okay and they ask a
question and then we have to answer it
all right can you do it yeah sure thank
you yeah he has to do a thing though
helpful advice with Bobby
kalila at Camp Queen and Prince and
court jester a few years ago I was lost
and doing nothing with my life however
my girlfriend helped set me on the right
path and now I have a rewarding career
in software development most if not all
all of my success I owe my hard work and
perseverance to her my question is how
can I help her set her on the right path
she's unhappy with her current job and
it seems like she's got one or two good
but a risky options to get out but has
yet to really make a move on them and is
unsure I'm feeling terrible that I can't
help her out what do I do
Carlo from Canada
well that was what okay the question is
how the girlfriend set him up on a good
path just there for him so how does he
return how does he leave her uh doesn't
know what honey but he wants to return
the favor or levi's setting her up no he
wants to uh he wants to do the same
thing for her she wants to get her a
good job on the or on the right path
yeah follow her dreams essentially what
can he do to something that's like the
hardest thing you could ever buy for
someone yeah yeah well first old we
don't even know what her dreams are you
know what you get you put a blindfold on
and then just say it's risky so it's
probably like not a normal 9 to 5 so if
she's what do you mean risky like a coal
miner kind of situation I want to see
something right now can I stand stand
yes stand up whatever she wants to
[ __ ] do you should always support
that right yeah so I don't know what her
dream is but yeah I don't we specifics
but you should try to help her make it
yeah I think all women need is just to
be told that that you can never allow
it's ok we support you yeah that's all I
need from men there's a second question
here this one's a good one but can I
just say something real quick though
I've been really getting into exFAT
hmm and I've been really getting into
this lady by the name of Sam Baily she
won the whole thing 2013 and when she
auditioned right she was like this like
frumpy white lady who just had kids and
a wife she likes soccer and she's like I
think I'm too old but um you know I have
to try
and she won the whole thing she's so
gifted there you go
wait does that one make you eat bugs and
stuff no she's a singing competition
okay and she won the whole thing but
whenever I look at that clip in the
beginning isn't Boyle know and everyone
thought she was you know Susan Boyles
not even Natalie what do you mean she's
not I don't think she's like that and
Bruns you didn't blow me away I know but
do you know why why because she all the
way that no because because she better
well let me say this right now if she
didn't look like that and she looked
like she looked like it's just a regular
2002 old girl hip girl she would have
been she would have made it it's because
of the fact that they made fun of when
she came out of that stage people
laughed in the audience and they they
you know and then she came out and did
that I think that had a lot to do with
her her look but this girl Sam Baily I'm
talking about isn't like that she's
legitimately Talent yeah but when she
said I have to try it makes me cry
because in life you always have to try
yeah and that's tonight's message
okay give second question I have a
second question
[Music]